there are enough weapons on show to wage
a war but gun lovers insisted this was a
peaceful protest a state of emergency
had been declared amid fears that
extremists would hijack a demonstration
protesting plans to tighten Virginia's
gun laws not here looking for a fight
and there may be some who are but I'd
say the vast majority are not there's
certainly geared up for a fight though
well yeah maybe why why would you feel
the need to come dressed with a
semi-automatic weapon just walking along
the street what's up what's the point of
doing that oh well so I can protect me
and my friends and that I can show off
that in America we can we can have these
things and protect you from walk though
anything you never know what how you
never know what's gonna happen right
it's entirely legal to walk the streets
of Virginia carrying a gun and dressed
for combat but on the day that
Virginians traditionally Lobby their
representatives on legislation a ban was
imposed on bringing weapons into the
grounds of the State Capitol
those who were armed stayed outside the
court firearms are part of America's
history and yeah I don't want to see
them getting taken away they are the
nicest comics most open-minded friendly
warm-hearted people they are nothing
like the media says it's just Chuck you
know but nice people is not who the
governor was expecting when he imposed a
state of emergency this includes out of
state militia groups and hate groups
planning to travel from across the
country to disrupt our democratic
process with acts of violence they are
not coming to peacefully protest they
are coming to intimidate and to cause
harm more than 1,500 people in the
United States were killed through
violent gun crime sure in 2019 more than
400 in mass shootings as well how on
earth do guns save lives in that context
because a gun the only thing that's
gonna stop a bad guy with a gun is a
good guy with a gun those who support
the reforms stayed away preventing
confrontation
the governor has overreacted I think
that he did that for the drama factor to
scare people away to to enforce things
that he didn't need to enforce despite
this huge turnout
opinion polls and the most recent
statewide elections suggest that a
majority of Virginians do support some
restrictions on gun ownership but any
attempt to part these people from their
guns would certainly meet resistance in
woods Sky News Richmond Virginia